[Music]
a somber day for the eight news now
family and extended family as we say
goodbye to once longtime anchor gary
waddell good evening and thank you for
joining us at five i'm kirstjen joyce
and i'm bryan loftis gary waddell passed
away thursday at the age of 77 he sat at
the anchor desk here for more than three
decades but his impact was felt far
beyond the television newsroom
during his 32 years at klas gary waddell
was known for his honesty and calm
demeanor on the air and his leadership
and mentorship behind the scenes he
spent many of his three decades at the
station sitting alongside paula francis
i get it
as often as anything else that
when bad things are happening you and
paula
make me feel like it's going to be ok
denise valdez sue louden and george
knapp on the evening news where news
comes first now gary waddell the
newscast anchored by gary and george won
upi's newscast of the year in 1986.
he was loved by everyone at the station
gary covered many of the events and
moments that left lasting impacts on our
city from the mgm fire in 1980 the
latest reports are that the fire is out
to the pepcon chemical explosion
at this morning's nevada delegation
meeting and brought us coverage from
national events like the 1996 democratic
convention in chicago and following
along with nevada's task force one as
they rescued people trapped in louisiana
by hurricane katrina in 2005. gary
arrived in las vegas in 1971 as a tv
reporter moving over to channel 8 in
1980 until his retirement in 2012. my
favorite line i think is don hewitts
when he talks about 60 minutes and
and the reason for 60 minutes and that
is tell me a story
and and from then to today that is still
the hallmark of this business his name
will forever be remembered as a
respected and iconic journalist in our
great city he was the longest serving
newscaster in las vegas history gary is
in the nevada broadcasters hall of fame
the klas hall of fame won a slew of
broadcasting awards and even as a street
named after him outside of work gary
loved riding his motorcycle he even
worked at a harley shop after he retired
and anyone who stopped by his desk
remembers his faithful pet tarantula
frankie i'm really going to miss being
in
i'm really going to miss being in the
center of the action when that's why
we're in the world
you know i mean not the world's ending
but you know when when something has
happened
earlier today i caught up with long time
eight news now hall of fame anchor paula
francis gary and paulo were a team for
three decades and she considered him a
genuine and devoted friend
if you knew him in person he
he was the greatest kindest friend
anyone could have and he would do
anything for a friend
gary was truly loved in our newsroom
always had time for everyone we were all
well aware of his tremendous talent as a
journalist during the newscast but paula
also shared just how fun gary could make
a commercial break
we were so involved as friends and we
were involved in the news and talking
about what was going on but gary was a
great joke teller and he could really
tell jokes well paula continued on that
she could never remember a joke making
her really the perfect audience you can
see the full interview with paula
francis on her friend and co-anchor gary
waddell on eightnewsnow.com
and he was truly a fantastic guy i've
had the pleasure of keeping up with him
over the years with many a lunch and ted
i know you worked along with gary we're
old-timers here now we got to work with
gary for years and realize what a
fantastic guy he was and i know he was
to you as well yeah i've known him
almost 10 years right
and in that 10 years he tried to get me
to buy a bmw motorcycle
never happened sorry gary but yeah one
thing that people don't realize uh what
a big heart he had right and and we
could have the most
breaking news situation but his calm
demeanor would just make everybody just
calm down and we'd get right back on
track gary we love you and you will be
missed